cuál de las siguientes se puede
representar por un vector elige todas
las opciones correctas y bueno recuerda
que un vector debe de tener dos cosas
muy importantes magnitud y dirección así
que vamos a buscar aquí algo que tenga
magnitud y dirección el primero es el
número 5 y bueno el número 5 claramente
tiene una magnitud una magnitud de 5
pero el 5 por sí mismo no tiene una
dirección por lo tanto esto no
representa un vector recuerda que para
hablar de vector lo que necesitamos es
especificar una dirección bien vayamos a
la otra el ángulo que mide 5 grados y
bueno es que nosotros podemos tener aquí
a nuestro plano cartesiano a imagínate
que es éste nuestro plano cartesiano lo
voy a dibujar por aquí y bueno aquí
tenemos al eje x al eje y este es mi eje
de las x ok este es mi eje de leyes ok y
fíjate que en este caso yo tengo
que el ángulo mide 5 grados es decir
mide 5 grados con respecto al eje de las
equis y se vería algo más o menos así
esta apertura es de 5 grados y fíjate
que en este caso si tenemos una
dirección tenemos una dirección de 5
grados con respecto al eje de las equis
pero no tenemos una magnitud es decir no
hay ningún punto en donde vayamos a
parar o no sabemos qué tan largo es este
vector por lo tanto no tenemos magnitud
y si no tenemos magnitud aunque tengamos
dirección y aunque tengamos sentido esto
no me representa un vector y bueno vamos
tachándolos de una vez el número 5 no
representa un vector el ángulo que me dé
5 grados tiene dirección pero no tiene
magnitud y por lo tanto no representa un
vector y sigue el punto 5 5 bien
pues con el punto 5,5 pasa algo bastante
interesante si nosotros pensamos como el
punto 5,5 como la cabeza como el punto
final del vector y pulsamos como el
punto inicial del vector el origen y es
más vamos a dibujarlo déjame poner aquí
mi eje de las x ok a este le voy a poner
mi eje y ok y pueda voy a contar 5 para
acá 1 2 3 4 5 aquí estoy en el 5 en x y
vamos a contar cinco para acá uno dos
tres cuatro y cinco y estoy en cinco en
bien y bueno si te das cuenta aquí tengo
al punto 55 ahora imagínate que yo me
tomo al punto 55 como el punto final de
este vector y como punto inicial al
origen es decir se vería algo más o
menos así si te das cuenta esto sí
representa a un vector si hablamos de
que este va a ser mi punto final mi
cabeza el vector mientras que éste es
nicola el vector y bueno si representa
un vector porque date cuenta que ahora
tenemos magnitud y dirección cuál es la
magnitud bueno pues la distancia que hay
del origen al punto 5,5 es la magnitud
de este vector y lo podemos calcular por
un teorema
y cuál es la dirección bueno la
dirección esencialmente es esta que
tenemos aquí justo estoy dibujando el
sector esta sería mi dirección este de
aquí así ya tengo magnitud y dirección y
bueno esto puede representar entonces a
un vector porque este punto 5,5 puede
representar a algo que tiene magnitud y
dirección por lo tanto lo voy a poner
justo así y al final tengo el resultado
de cinco más cinco pero el resultado de
cinco más cinco es 10 lo cual es un
número y regresaría al caso de aquí
arriba el número 10 el cual tiene
magnitud pero no tiene dirección y por
lo tanto el resultado del 55 esto no es
mi respuesta correcta y ya está
el punto 5,5 es la opción correcta de
este ejercicio